He is the most famous person on the
planet and is the most divisive,
equally loved equally of horse.
It is impossible not to have an opinion
about the brash Twitter loving 45th
president of the United States.
Yet few people truly understand
what makes Trump Trump.
By going back into his past,
we are able to gain valuable insight into
the vast complexities that make up the
man.
In this week's biographics,
we're looking at the Donald's before you
took up residence at 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue.
Donald John Trump was born on June the
14th 1946 the fourth of five children do
Fred Trump and Mary McLeod,
Donald's grandfather,
Bosco Nicknames Frederick my
greatest in 1885 from Germany.
He brought with him a reputation as
one of the finest builders of his
generation.
Frederick helps to change the face
of Queens with his building projects.
They primarily consisted of
the construction of solids,
the basic brick rental apartments.
Fred followed his father's path and
became a prominent residential developer.
By the time Donald was in his teen years.
His father had a mass more than 27,000
apartments in such Brooklyn suburbs as
Flatbush,
sheepshead bay,
Bensonhurst,
and Brighton beach.
He also has extensive properties in the
Queens neighborhoods of Coney islands
and Jamaica estates.
In addition to his
residential housing portfolio,
Fred moved into commercial developments
during the depression years if the 30s
he built Trump markets,
which was a supermarkets,
builds on the concepts of save yourself
and save with war on the horizon.
He also got into construction
on military basis.
Donald's mother,
Mary Macleod,
Trump was at Scottish heritage.
She met frank in the early
1930 [inaudible] as a teenager
when they were married
in 1936 she was just 24 years old.
They settled into a 23
room house in Queens.
Vows was extravagance
with a colonial style,
portico,
frame entrance and six
imposing white marble pillars.
Freds two Cadillac's FCT one and
FCT too well parked in the driveway.
The trumps,
well one of the few families have an
intercom system installed in their home,
not to mention a chauffeur
and a personal butler.
Mrs. Trump was also a philanthropist
who became passionately involved in a
number of causes that
were close to her heart.
She was the main driving force of the
ladies helper of Jamaica facility as well
as the Jamaica daycare nursery.
Mary was also an ardent supporter of the
national kidney establishments if New
York and the group mainstreaming
partners of incredible neck New York,
which provided help for people who
were crippled of all of his children.
Young Donald showed the most interest
in his father's business ventures as a
result of Fred would sometimes take the
boy onto construction sites with him as
he developed his own personality.
Donald's gains a bit of
a reputation as a bully.
There's parents were lacks in
imposing discipline upon him.
On one occasion,
the trumps neighbor Martha Burnham,
came home to find the four year old
Donald throwing stones at our son.
Dennis.
Donald had apparently targeted
dentists as an easy mark for his venom.
Martha warns her son to stay
away from the nasty crump boy.
By the time he was age,
Donald's was the leader
of a group of young thugs.
He would ride around
Queens on their bicycles,
anything else,
insults to people and stopping to deal
with other youngsters who they didn't
like the look off.
He was known for saying what's every
one says and acting impulsively.
Fred's enrolled.
Donald's adds a private education
facility in forest hills called Kew forest
school.
Fred to happens to be on the
board of trustees for that school.
This fact seems to have
emboldened Donald's in his
way with behaviors taking the
lead amongst a bunch of boys
who were constant troublemakers.
He would pull,
the girls have purposely bumping into
other students' desks and it's talk out of
turn in class.
Donald's grades,
they were mediocre at best.
This was mainly due though to lack of
application rather than lack of ability,
a situation that has greatly
frustrated as teachers.
However,
on the playgrounds and the sports fields,
he displayed considerable ability.
His favorite gym game was dodgeball.
He displayed great dexterity and avoiding
balls that were thrown at him and he
was often the last man standing outdoors.
He excelled at baseball.
He was a talented player and a fierce
competitor as a sixth grader is batting
power.
Was exceptional when he came up to bat.
The defending side would
have to extend its field,
is way out in order to handle
his daunting right arm swing.
One morning when he was 12 years old,
Donald and his friend Peter Brands
jumps on the train to Manhattan.
Such an excursion had not been authorized
by Donald's parents getting off at
Fifth Avenue and 53rd they spent the day
scrolling through central park buying
curiosity,
is it novelty stores and
wandering among the homeless.
One of the items that Donald
purchased was a switchblade knife.
It was a month later that Fred discovered
the knife and the story of Donald's
unauthorized trip to the
city was uncovered Fred.
He was outraged.
He finally came to the realization
that Donald was out of control and that
something had to be done.
Fred decided that his fourth son was in
dire need of some external discipline.
He enrolled Donald's at the rosy and
military boarding school about 70 miles
away.
There would be no more comfortable living
in the mansion and swelling around the
neighborhood.
Mcdonald's and implementing
this new strategy.
Fred acted quickly,
not even giving his son
time to say as fat wells,
life was indeed vastly different.
At the military school,
the boys were required to wear a uniform
that consisted of a thick fleece,
pullover and pants and alarm woke them
up early in the morning and their entire
day was regulated by the clock.
Donald's life was now completely
controlled by Theodore
had Tobias the hands on
school administrator.
Tobias was a no nonsense World War II
veteran who demanded excellence from his
new recruits.
He knew that many of the boys that were
sent to him with that to be toughened up
and to have discipline imposed upon them,
and he took that
responsibility very seriously.
As you might imagine,
all of this was a pretty
serious shock for Donald's.
His initial reaction was resentments
and is a natural tendency to buck the
system.
He seemed racked up a number of charges,
including not making as bad and
not properly cleaning the sink.
Yes,
administrative.
Tobias saw something
else in the young Trump.
The boy was incredibly driven and
always had a desire to be number one,
realizing the bucking the system was
only going to get him in deeper trouble.
Don't always began trying
to follow the rules.
The biggest improvement was with regard
to his personal orderliness and won
awards for the cleanliness
of his personal area.
Indeed,
his orderliness bordered on
the obsessive winning him,
the nickname Mr fastidious,
Donald's loud mouth Busta quieten down.
As discipline was injected into a system,
he became soft spoken and had
an air of self confidence.
He developed friendships despite often
being regarded as a bit cocky and
bragging too much about
his father's wealth.
Then during his senior year,
Donald was made a company captain.
This puts him in a position that
have oversight over younger boys.
He inspected that personal space and was
responsible for generally keeping them
in order.
His reputation was such that he very
rarely had to raise his voice at his
charges.
A simple step sometimes accompanied by a
raised eyebrow was enough to impart his
displeasure in his position.
His company caps in Trump proved
himself to be an effective delegator.
This develops to the extent that he would
give the job of inspection of the boys
under his commands to others while he
returned to his room to recline on his
bed.
This practice soon came to the
attention of administrative Tobias,
who was less than impressed.
He removed to Trump from his role as
company caps in and gave him a school
administrative position in stat.
Donald's then runs onto frame this as
a promotion for his stellar job in his
previous role.
So following his graduation from racier
at the age of 18 he enrolled at Fordham
University in the Bronx
to study real estate.
He was determined to follow in his
father's footsteps and enter the world of
real estate developments.
Of course,
he was going to do it bigger and better
than his old men and to do that if
figured he needed a real estate degree.
In 1966 after two years at Fordham,
Donald transferred to the University
of Wharton Business College.
Here he was out of place while
coming from a background of money,
he didn't have the Ivy
League breeding of those.
He rubbed shoulders with.
He was rough and obtuse and soon proved
himself to be the proverbial round hole
in a landscape of square pegs.
On his first day,
the lecturer asked why every student there
had decided to study real estate when
it came to his turn.
Donald stood up and declared that he
was going to become the king of New York
City when it came to
the real estate business
drum.
Graduated from Wharton in 1968 returning
to New York with a degree in real
estate.
At this time,
he was eligible for the draft
to serve his country in Vietnam.
However,
race,
September,
1968 physical exam resulted in a medical
suspension due to bone goads in his
heels,
setting himself up in
an apartment in Queens.
Trump began working for his father
in early 1969 from very start,
he fells deep seated need to prove
to his father that he was a supremely
talented real estate man.
The Trump way of doing business
was called into question.
In 1973 when a handful of tenants took
up a class action lawsuits against the
company claiming racial discrimination
in violation of the Fair Housing Act.
The case was as impossible to prove.
However,
and the Trump organization paid a small
settlements without any admission of
guilt.
Around this same time,
Donald was promoted to president of the
company and his first act was to re name
the company.
The format Elizabeth Trump and
son became the Trump organization.
One of his next moves was to hire
aggressive attorney Roy Cohn.
Cohn had a reputation as a bulldog,
Goliath.
If anyone dad's a farmer,
suits against those who he works for,
he would go out and destroy them.
In 1975 Donald's,
Matt,
Ivana,
Maria is they'll niche Guevara.
She was a beautiful sports scare who
hails from Czechoslovakia or Romans.
Seen Blossoms,
ends after a two year courtship.
The couple were married
over the next five years.
Ivana was given management responsibility
and a number of business ventures.
She also bore Trump three children,
Donald jr Ivanka and Eric.
The vast majority of Fred Trump's business
was centered on middle income housing
in Brooklyn,
queens and Staten Island's to Donald's.
This was small time.
He wanted to break into the large scale
commercial real estate and the heart of
the big apple.
He's had his sights on
a project in Manhattan.
His target was the Commodore Hotel.
The commodore was a derelict to
2003 white elephants on 42nd street.
Trump intend to do completely remodel
this into an upmarket Hyatt hotel.
The highest end buyer was
run by the Pritzker family.
Despite having presences
all over the states,
they have no representation in New York,
but the area surrounding the commodore
was extremely CD and the Pritzkers were
in need of some serious
convincing for Donald.
However,
the CD environments and the decrepit
state of the hotel meant that he would be
able to pick up the property at a
steal of a price to make the purchase.
However,
he would need to borrow a lot of money.
The finance was secured by bank loans.
There were underwritten by both Fred
Trump and the highest organisation.
Donald Aussie managed to secure a 40
year tax exemption on the building.
The renovation of the commodore and its
metamorphosis into the Grand Hyatt hotel
proved to be a great success with Trump
winning accolades from the city fathers
along with an award for the tasteful and
creative recycling of a distinguished
hotel.
The grand science projects coupled with
the reflected reputation of his father,
established Donald's as a legitimate
player in the New York commercial real
estate markets.
Sure.
Shortly
after the completion of
the highest projects,
Trump began negotiations to develop
a 58 story building on Fifth Avenue
adjacents to famous New York
landmark Tiffany and company.
This $200 million developments
was to be Trump's masterpiece.
It would feature a six story atrium
that was lined with pink marble as an 80
foot waterfall.
Depends.
House was to be Donald's personal living
quarters with this officer's just below
the first couple of floors would then
feature some of the world's most famous
retailers.
The building opens in 1983
and was named Trump tower.
It's received international attention
and was attended by a number of
celebrities at the same time that
Donald was working on Trump tower.
A local New York buildup was attempting
to repair derelict Wollman skating rink
after two and a half months.
The work that style matters,
there was a lot of public dissatisfaction
that the ring was not reopened on
time.
Then Donald interjected himself into the
whole affair when he wrote a letter to
the mayor stating that
he could supercharge the
projects and just bring it in.
Well under budget.
The mayor responded by calling his bluff.
Donald went straight to a concrete that
he had a working relationship with.
He convinced them to take the Wollman
rink projects on the for free with a
guarantee that the publicity it would
bring would far outweigh the costs
involved.
The projects when's ahead on that basis
and was completed under time and under
budget by three quarters
of a million dollars.
The publicity ans public appreciation
that the woman rig project brought in was
huge,
but it was all directed
towards Donald Trump.
The contractor who had done the
heavy work without payments,
barely even got him mentioned.
1980 you saw Trump moving
into the gambling business.
He acquired all of the necessary
licenses and then purchased a property in
Atlantic city to do this project.
He partners with the Holiday Inn
cooperation the parent's company of harass
casinos.
In 1984 the facility opens
as Porras at Trump plaza.
The casino was a great success.
Wetting Trump's appetite for more.
He actively sought out casinos
that had failed gambling licenses.
Finding one in the form
of the Atlantic City,
Hilton Hotels Casino.
He acquired the property spending $310
million on the purchase and upgrade it
later reopened as Trump castle
always wanting to go one better.
Trump took over developments of the
largest casino in the world at the time,
the Taj Mahal,
the Trump Taj Mahal opens in 1990 however,
Trump had to go into extreme
debt in order to open the doors.
Revenues would have to average $1
million per day in order to cover costs.
This was simply an unheard of number and
the reality was that it was never going
to happen.
Trump indeed had to go through major
bankruptcy restructuring in order to keep
the casino going.
Eventually ending up with
just a 10% ownership stake.
Around this same time,
Trump also established Trump's
hotels and casino resorts,
which became a publicly traded company
throughout the 1980s and nineties
nineties from never let up on
his real estate developments.
Despite his financial problems.
In 1985 he purchased a 76 acres of
western Manhattan in order to create a
television city complex.
Then in 1988 he purchased the
Plaza Hotel for $407 million.
Then 1989 saw his first
investment in Florida.
By this time,
he had also acquired a number of
golf results across the country.
In 1992 Trump hit the headlines
for all the wrong reasons.
When his affair with a 23 year old
actress named Marla Maples was exposed.
Display Room is if on,
I refuse to believe truth until Marla
followed the trumps on a skiing trip and
confronted Ivana with the news that
Donald was in love with her and that Ivana
best give up on him.
This was too much for Ivana.
She filed for divorce,
leaving maples free to marry Donald's,
which he did in 1993 they had one child
together who they named Tiffany after
the famous New York department store.
The marriage,
though it was rocky from the start
and end in divorce in 1999 ironically,
the proceedings were instigated by
Donald's when he learns that his wife was
having an affair.
Donald was then associated with a number
of women in the early two thousands
back in 1998 he had met a Slovenian
but by the name of Melania conops.
Over the next few years,
that relationship develops at the points
where Melania became Donald's constant
companion.
They were engaged in 2004 and married
on January the 22nd 2005 and Palm Beach,
Florida.
The couples.
Only child baron.
William Trump was born on March the
20th 2006 on October the 21st at Trump
hotels,
casinos and resorts restructured its
death resulting in Trump's ownership.
If the company dropping from 59 to 27%
the company applied for bankruptcy.
It reemerged as Trump
entertainment resorts holdings.
Trump now put a premium on pushing his
brands with the Trump logo being placed
on all manner of products.
Even released his own game.
Donald Trump's real estate tycoon,
Trump's political views,
they've undergone a metamorphosis
over the years up in Zillow.
1987 he was a democrat.
However,
in that year,
he registered for the first time as a
republican toying with the idea of running
for office.
He placed full page ads in three
papers espousing his views,
which were that America,
and you'd have to stop propping up other
countries and start looking after it.
Same people.
In October of 1999 Trump established
and exploratory panel to assess the
viability of his running for the reform
party's candidate for president from
nominee in two thousands it was decided
that his lack of profile on the west
coast would be too much of a detriment.
This led him to pass on the
opportunity from that point onwards.
However,
he bided his time and it's increasingly
made political comment for public
consumption.
In 2003 Trump ventured into the world
of reality television when he became the
executive producer and
star of the apprentice.
The show in which contenders go through
a series of challenges do you when a job
has Trump's apprentice was a huge success.
It propelled Donald Trump to worldwide
recognition status in one and a star on
the Hollywood walk of fame from reentered
the political arena in 2001 when he
raised questions about the legitimacy
of President Barack Obama's birth
certificates.
He doggedly held to this view despite
Obama's insistence that he was born on us
soil.
He's serious and he considered running
for the top office again in 2012 but
again decided that the time wasn't right.
Then on June the 16th 2015 he famously
announced from Trump plaza that he would
be throwing his hat into the ring for the
Republican nomination for president in
2016 few people to come seriously but
serious he was and history will record him
for better or as the 45th
president of the United States.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the race and as always,
thank you for watching.